Now we turn to another problem
that we'll be able to tackle
with the dynamic programming paradigm,
chain matrix multiplication.
>> We are given a sequence of
matrices of sizes m0 by m1, m1 by m2,
and so forth.
And we want to compute the product
A1 through An efficiently.
Note how the dimensions
here are arranged so
that such a product is always defined.
The number of columns in one matrix
always matches the number of
rows in the next.
First, recall that the product of a m by
n matrix with an n by p matrix produces
a matrix that is m by p, and that
the cost of computing each entry is n.
Each entry can be thought of as the dot
product between the corresponding row
of the first matrix, and
the corresponding column of the second.
Both these vectors have n entries.
In total, we have about m
times n times p additions, and
as many multiplications.
Next, recall that matrix
multiplication is associative.
Thus, as far as the answer goes, it
doesn't matter whether I multiply A and
B first and
then multiply that product by C.
Or if I multiplied B and C first and
then multiplied that product by A.
The product of all these
three will be the same, but
the number of operations may not be.
let's see this with an example.
We will take matrices with
these dimensions here and
count the number of multiplications
using both of these strategies.
If we multiply A and B first, then we
spend 50 times 20 times 50 computing AB.
This matrix will have 50 rows and
50 columns, so
its product with C will take 50 times
50 times 1, for a total of 52,500.
On the other hand, if we multiply B and
C first, this costs 20 times 50 times 1.
This produces a 20 by 1 matrix.
And multiplying it by a costs
50 times 20 times 1, for
a total of only 2,000,
a big improvement.
So it's important to be clever
about which order we choose for
multiplying these matrices.